was ist das gang über die promenade auch
wenn die praxen immer nur drauf leute
kommen zum zweiten teil unserer budget
reise in deutschland wir sind jetzt
gerade hier im hamburger hauptbahnhof
ihr wisst ja dass ich bei der ganzen
sache ist mit sieben euro am tag urlaub
zu machen ohne gute zeit zu haben bisher
ihren hamburger das beste teams hier
leute machen uns auf den weg zu unserem
nächsten ziel was das ist wollte jetzt
gleich sehen wir jetzt unser geld von
dave und auch heute wieder essen und
spaß haben zu können und dann
geschlossen und folge geht euch dass wir
werden ja einmal sprechen feinste
delikatessen 60 oder sogar bananen post
auch zu 160 für mich und date ein ganzes
steht aber selbst ein luxus ich kann mir
das erste was am meisten sinn so lernen
gibt und so einer salatbar aber ich habe
das geld ja sie hat die wir nicht hier
und ihr seht dass wir sind insgesamt auf
7 zu kommen gibt es und was ich alles
geholt haben wir haben hier voll kontos
bananen war war schweine irrten käse und
schinken
können wir jetzt wie sie unser
mittagessen mit bestreiten können unser
ab dessen
zusammenhalten und leute ich muss mir
was sagen ich hatte gab es eine
erkenntnis sich laufbahn solchen
supermarkt und dachte halt so ein
bisschen auf das budget was ich so
ausgeben und allgemein denkst du über
nacht geben viel geld aus für den tag da
ist mir aufgefallen wie viel geld ich
eigentlich sie verschwende ich weiß das
kannst du ich bestellt schon ab und zu
messen
die das geld sinnlos sachen aus nachdem
sie hat den bekannten vor was nicht
gerade gemacht hat einfach
meerschweinchen holen zu können für 150
im krassen gegensatz dazu steht dennoch
nicht erleuchtet dave der ziel salat 14
euro
[Musik]
ich habe 14 euro insgesamt günstiger
gibt es immer noch viel geld aus florida
mit irgendwie 23 mal
ich war aber leute dahinter uns ist ganz
schön unser zug eingefahren der uns nach
rostock bringen wird von horst geht's
weiter nach kühlungsborn pate bekannte
von uns wo wir unterkommen können dass
unser nächstes ziel leute und jetzt
machen wir uns auf den weg mit
[Musik]
richtig so ich habe nichts gehört hat
lennart produziert trainer hält er ist
bestürzt
der kleine pfennigfuchser wo sind wir
wollen weiterfahren
rostock sowie eigenleistung heute aber
die meisten vom feld bisher jüngste baby
bei den junioren und jetzt heute sind
zwei schülern angekommen geht es mal um
mit mir gebt euch was er ist stabil
leute die so sebastian dass der zukunft
ich möchte mich weiter sebastian aus der
vergangenheit die mir gerade zuschauern
eine sache vergessen hat und so wisst
ihr wenn ihr das erste schon gesehen hat
dass wir den trifft sich dort schon
zusammen mit der deutschen bahn machen
genau wir haben im sommer ticket ist ein
ticket für leute unter 7 20 jahren dort
bekommt ihr vielfach deutschen die euch
verlegen können wir unter 18 sein kostet
das 19 90 pro partie zwischen 18 und 26
seiten 24 90 programm das team reisen
und alle infos zum sommer
artikelbeschreibung erst jetzt weiter an
silvester aber sebastian befinden wir
uns aber wir befinden uns an dem
ostseebad kühlungsborn zwischenzeitlich
hat sich auch zu uns hier geben dass
unser reisepartner maximilian dann
leider erkrankt ist hat er immer mehr
abgepackt kopf gucken was man machen
kann aber vielleicht ja noch nicht in
guter dinge hier eine schöne zeit
zusammen mit oder ohne max ist uns
völlig egal
wir wollen das auch so soll ich jetzt
geht es erstmal diesen ausblick
[Musik]
und hunde kalt da ist klar wenn man aber
auch den moment fühlt einfach spaß am
leben hat im moment übrigens von max
göldi nicht zu sehen war max ist ja
wirklich bisschen ob der autor hat jetzt
die aufgabe übernommen in der wohnung zu
bleiben und schon mal fürs essen
einzukaufen nacherzählt auf die kraft
und das essen auch zu kochen wir
natürlich aber ich hoffe ich halt was
soll der scheiß alter müssten spaß am
strand haben kriegen wir auf essen
gekocht und eingekauft und gehabt das
wird ja was soll das mal nein und ja
dann ist es beim kochen das mikro
gestorben deswegen versuche ich das
gerade für euch nach was wir gemacht
haben ist nicht ganz einfach werden uns
heute die nie gemacht mit thunfisch und
paprika das ganze hat sechs euro 16
gekostet wir hier sehen ob aber lecker
da wollte natürlich auch bei uns mit
essen aber auch übertreiben deswegen hat
er sich noch parmesan geholt max und ich
konnte wirklich kein parmesan leisten
und ja wir sind allerdings nach dem
essen auf der couch eingepennt und
dementsprechend geht es weiter mit dem
nächsten tag so guten morgen an tag 4
aus kühlungsborn ich habe beide budgets
für die beiden leute schon fährt gemacht
max ist leider leider wirklich auf
werden die gesundheit tausender der ja
ich hab mich schon hungern lassen wir
jetzt supermarkt hätten wir mal direkt
um die ecke diese leute und leute ich
habe für magst du mich fürs frühstück
aus wie m 6 eur 58 dabei sind dabei
diese aber ich es das wohl dafür maximal
der kranken cola salzstangen berührt
sind dabei bargeld und sogar noch
kleinen us geschichte der erlaubt ist es
jetzt definitiv wieder abgehoben
euro um wie sie unterwegs sollte das ist
der erste richtige tag ganzen tag fahren
ich bin fucking halbleiter gebt euch das
wetter der himmel hatte kommt ja der
himmel ist blau ist einfach so die
richtige urlaubsstimmung bei uns so
angekommen oder selbst er für mich wer
jetzt nicht die promenade langsam eine
gute zeit haben und gucken was wir mit
unserem tages budget sogar was ich mit
einem tages belaufen ihr seht dass da
vorne ich würde es machen
das ist gerade im gesehen hat ich muss
das machen doch ich musste machen aber
probleme ist glaube ich bin wie ich bin
wahrscheinlich zu schwer dafür ist
wahrscheinlich so viel kosten aber ich
hoffe es war also grundsätzlich mag es
liegt ja heute im bett und ist
salzstangen mavie könntest du ja nach
beim budget fragen und für 6 euro sechs
minuten springt er weiß nicht wie viele
früchte
ich glaube auch drei euro pro person
drei euro profession wir haben noch vier
euro pro person
das kostet sechs euro abgibt oder dave
machst einfach mal spendablen tele2
jetzt einspringen
also man sieht sebastian 21
das sind 23 23 95 gewährt ich würde
sagen man sieht nur leute in ähnlichem
gewicht und endlich im alter muss das
jetzt machen sonne scheint die musik
läuft so dass die möglichkeit einfach zu
jumpen dinge muss heute vergeblich und
außerdem werde ich mitkommen sebastian
ich komme mit dir und filme vom neben
trampolin probiert ich zu
ich habe erfahren heute spezial gute für
große zittern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
antwort ich liebe twilight hat die sache
ist und da bewegt ist ok weil drehst
einmal du weißt wo du wirst dann ok ich
muss noch einmal drehen wenn du machen
willst du zweimal davon wissen wohin du
musst du dich noch heute hier gedreht
es lohnt sich einfach immer wieder sich
mit leuten zu connect irgend einfach zu
schauen was daraus wird
dieser ungeplanten bekanntschaften ist
einfach hammer leute wie ihr diese
trampolin hier in kühlungsborn sind und
diese nähren man dann müsst ihr das hier
am richtigen ort
ja leute was wir einen ehren bruder war
das alter das hat mich schon richtig
mein tag wird das ist so das wird auf
jeden fall stay von der reise hängen
bleiben auch lange zeit wie geil wie das
einfach im moment ist so ein erlebnis
sonne scheint die leute draußen sind
auch alle so mehr ganz so glücklich
jahren geht also auch der typ mit dem
wir da gerade rumgehangen haben die
legal übel geil alter und ohne wird ich
habe schon so oft die wahrscheinlich
auch viel mehr geld ausgegeben und dann
nicht ansatzweise so gut wird
das zu schätzen können jetzt zum hasen
[Musik]
bei einem kurzen zwischenstopp
angekommen hast du lust auf ein eis ja
dann kauf dir hört man dann sagt er
guten hunger ich genieße mein bruder hat
sich auch einfach kaufen können
wir haben heute zwei euro die der drei
euro heute sparsamen luxus leben geht
weiter
wenn mir gerade mit dem zeug von gestern
morgen ein brot zusammengepasst und hier
genießt es bei diesem wunderbaren auch
bestens ich will ja die alten heutiger
ich werde jetzt bei euch auch noch hatte
alltag im spaß im urlaub geht warten
[Musik]
hat
darüber sind mag es auch wieder am leben
ist tomatensuppe focaccia für drei
personen 625 m budget und ja das haben
wir geschafft
dave hat für vier euro einen minecraft
zeug kaufen besitzen hier seit
geschlagenen drei stunden danach
minecraft darauf mein körper sich heute
eigentlich schon dass mein nächster
woche leute herzlich willkommen zu
unserem frühstücks von sexarbeit kürzen
wir uns gerne mal aufgefallen dass wir
eigentlich immer so zwischen 6 und 7
euro ausgeben wir haben hier für die
fairtrade bananen normalen trade bananen
okay ich hab mir das hier gönnt
vegetarische hat welchen eigentlich bin
ich kein vegetarier aber der mich
angemacht und mein vater falsch das ist
ja auch nicht schlecht macht hätten
zumindest etwas noch mal groß sollten
was jetzt machen wir die leute habt ihr
auch schon im titel dieses videos
gesehen denn wir haben hier eine
wunderschöne karte der ausziehen wir
haben alle was willst du machen werden
dass wir werden hier bereicherte karte
auf meinen die für gewisse aufgaben
stehen oder werden uns sehr saftige
aufgaben überlegen und dann werden wir
alle auch selbst hinter der kamera auf
diese karte werfen und die aufgabe auf
der der fall landet einfach erfüllen
müssen wie wir es erst unser frische
keinen fall
danach will change hier und danach gehen
wir an unseren dritten und letzten
zielunternehmen wissen wie ihr seht aber
jetzt erstmal film ab für okay leute da
sind wir da drüben ist für uns unsere
landkarte aufgebaut mit sechs
verschiedenen zonen wie sechs
verschiedene aufgaben bedeuten weil ich
ja ganz gut sagen normalerweise leute
ist ja so dass man der quasi ohne
landkarte in photoshop macht so was auf
dem platz und die dann quasi
also mal wieso das land hat den
photoshop machten dann die einzelnen
zonen sein foto schon mal aus bild via
meisterlich hardcore-modus weil wir bis
heute wir sind seit fünf tage auf einer
reise die mir keinen drucker keinen gar
nicht sprechen da musst du echte
landkarte genommen haben darauf teil der
gemeinden wir sind hier und dauernd
irgendwas die zahlen bedeuten also für
welche aufgaben die stehen und wir
werfen dann müssen die aufgabe die für
das fest steht dass wir getroffen haben
machen was man vielleicht noch dazu
sagen sollte ist das einst der feldern
freifeld ist als bedeute wenn man glück
hat und dieses eine festschrift muss man
keine aufgabe liege und auch nicht alle
aufgaben sie gleich schwierig als wir
ein paar die richtig eklig sind und ein
paar diese okay sind aber trotzdem
schmerzhaft übrigens dave hinter der
kamera judas auch mitmachen
übrigens sollte jeder wirft nur einmal
das heißt wenn man ein gutes feld
erwischen sollte idealerweise dass du
hast du musst nichts machen kann der
boss
es geht jetzt darum wer den ersten wurf
hat war logischerweise darf ihre change
nur ein einziges mal gemacht werden wenn
man jetzt gewinnt und beim ersten wurf
dem glückstreffer landet ist man der
abschüsse die schere stein papier schere
stein papier also was daraus schere
stein papier schere stein papier
ich habe anfang leute bitte ich war
gestern kein gitter muss sie gesteht zu
machen oder sonst irgendwas ich will
einfach jetzt die fünf treffen und
draußen seid ihr bereit
ja ich brauche das glück von marcel
scorpions die augen zu
ja ok praxis schaut kurz danach in einem
schlauen lexikon die nummer sechs ist
eine stunde lang nichts sagen
ich habe mir hier leute ich mache mir
jetzt mal ganz entspannt hier eine
stoppuhr an eine stunde und microsys
heimischen gelangen nicht sein
ganz kurz mal sagen leute ich glaube es
doch wer also wenn du dich jetzt wenn er
sagt das willst dann können wir nicht
auch schon erscheint jetzt ausnehmen
habe jetzt eine dann kannst du einfach
da musst du nicht mit machen aber man
sagt einfach nur so johann bock man ja
dann muss das nicht machen hat etwas
gesagt ich bin dran ich bin okay wenn
wir zehn stunden an der kameraleute da
wirkt als zweiter wie gesagt die fünf
ist was gutes alles andere ist schlecht
onyx getroffen noch mal
[Musik]
viel spaß wünscht sich ganz viel
sprachiger ist seit jahren der einzige
möglichkeit mir irgendwas keine richtung
machen wir haben noch 50 liegestütze
krebs kann über die promenade dadina
sein und leute auch denke ich noch den
weg war das schlimmste für mich ist
fremde leute an zu labern und hat dem
weg zu fragen ist schlimmste für mich
geht gar nichts aber klar ist aber klaus
jäger bitte alles nämlich die 35 schon
geworfen
[Musik]
die promenade auffällig sind immer nur
das okay also leute wie was soll ich
laufen formular angekommen würde sagen
du läufst von diesen blumenkübel bis zu
dem nach vorne
wir laufen noch immer schön ein paar
leute hier so schöne zuschauerschaft ja
sowas ja worauf wartest du gemacht
so was sagst du dazu max bisschen
schneller vielleicht nicht so schlimm
worauf wartest du nicht so schlimm
sebastian also die leute die sich hier
anregungen sind auch nicht besonders
überzeugt von seiner aktion magst kannst
du bitte in der stille anfeuern
ich gebe dir mein komplettes tage später
morgen und übermorgen sagte einfach ja
ich will ja ich will haben
ich habe extra nicht geschaut wieso die
leute um mich herum waren sehr
verwundert wenn du nicht du bist und
damenclubs braun leider schon abgelaufen
leute wie macht jetzt auf den weg zu
unserem dritten und letzten reiseziel
und was das ist
im nächsten video also heute vielen dank
an die deutsche bahn ist alles möglich
gemacht hatten wir ja auch prompt auf
den trip mit dem sommerhit hat dann
zieht euch dass wir jetzt wie ihr seht
dass es verfügbar
[Musik]